the Joe Rogan experience you you do that
one you do that one very small podcast
where you just have small like three or
four minute clips yeah so what it was I
did a tweet storm called how to get rich
without getting lucky and it got pretty
popular in Twitter and it's really about
wealth creation I just use the click
baby title and it's trying to basically
lay out timeless principles of wealth
creation that if you absorb them you
become the kind of person who can create
wealth create business make money and my
theory behind that is like there are
three things
everybody wants there's actually more
than three but listen let's just start
with three the three basics everybody
wants to be wealthy everybody wants to
be happy and everybody wants to be fit
and I know there's a lot of rich you
signal that goes on like we don't want
money and you know I don't care about
being happy and happiness is for stupid
people but let's face it like you want
to be rich and happy and healthy yeah
that's the trifecta now of course you
also want to internally calm state of
mind you want a loving household so
there are other things that come into it
but those three I think they can
actually be taught right and a fitness
I'm not gonna teach there a lot of
people who you've had on here including
yourself who know a heck of a lot more
about fitness and health than I do but I
was born poor and miserable and I'm now
pretty well-off and I'm very happy and I
don't and I worked at those and so I've
learned a few things there are some
principles and so I try to lay them out
but in a timeless manner where you can
kind of figure it out yourself because
at the end of the day I can't really
teach anything I can only inspire you
and maybe give you a few hooks so you
can remember things when they happen or
put it put a name to them so this
podcast actually ended up explaining
this tweet storm so there's a tweet
storm with like 36 38 tweets got very
famous got translated dozens of
languages and these were principles that
I came up with for myself when I was
really young around 13 14 and I've been
carrying them in my head for 30 years
and I've been sort of living them and
over time I just realized like sadly or
fortunately the thing that I got really
good at was looking at businesses and
figuring out the point of maximum
leverage to actually create wealth and
capture some of that and do it in a very
long-term kind of way
but the you know banker hmm crash the
economy yeah all that kind of way but
you know build businesses and help
people and provide value kind of way
especially when applied to modern
technology and leverage in this age of
infinite leverage that we live in so the
podcast is just explaining each tweet so
these are little three four five minutes
snippets I don't like to say the same
thing twice I don't like to explain in
detail I just I feel like if you have
something original and interesting to
say you should say it otherwise it's
probably been said better so that
podcast tries to be information dense it
tries to be very concise it tries to be
high-impact it tries to be timeless and
it has all the information I think you
need the principles that if you absorb
these and you work hard over ten years
you get what you want so I've got the
one on wealth creation I'm going to
attempt to do one on happiness is a big
word but you know happiness and inner
peace and calm and all that because what
you want is you don't want to be the guy
who succeeds in life while being high
strung high stress and unhappy and
leaving a trail of emotional wreckage
with you and your loved ones which is
more common than not because you got to
focus and yes it's very hard to be great
at everything you want to be the guy or
the gal who gets there calmly you know
quietly without struggle now you want to
be the person who's the when there's a
crisis going on you want to be the
comest coolest cucumber in the room who
still also figures out the correct
answer
[Applause]